hello everybody
hey
nice uh
very good very good to meet you uh maria
i will start with you this is a
powerful powerful movie
and it brings so much awareness and
sometimes they're stories that you know
are good and you want to tell them other
times there's stories that are important
and you have to tell them is this one of
those
yes um
it is one of both and they're pretty
much connected because i mean i was
singing a lot because i'm i like to be a
philosopher here and there and say
always like we need
movies to make us feel something but
when something makes you feel something
makes you do something makes you act not
only react by oh ow cry love and things
like that and with movies like women to
cry where the where the theme is
something that pretty much intrigues all
of us not only women but men as well
because
have they actually seen behind the scene
what is happening in the women's head uh
so it is crucial to be to be seen it's a
story that we need to stop tell the
world and it's a story that also pretty
much makes you feel something so yeah
it is definitely one of them and uh mina
and vezila uh where did the story come
from
what did you see what inspired this what
were the characters based on
to be honest very much like all our
films very deeply rooted in reality in
this case bachelor's family who came as
firsthand inspiration
and we had a hard process because we we
wanted to be true to the reality because
when you transform reality you take a
big responsibility you have to
really look at it with every possible
detail
yeah and
it started always targeting inspiration
from my twin sister who is playing
veronica
who has postnatal depression she is my
real sister in life as well
and anna who is slaying on i saw my real
older sister in the film
we come from family which are actors
who is playing laura um
sonia's sister
she's also part of my family and it's
kind of very
unique maybe one time
uh
experience that you make a film but
at the same time you are going deep in
you in the wounds of your own family and
this is very interesting
maria was casted for the part and she
embraced
all the emotions so
um
very like inside she was very
supportive
through the whole process it was very
interesting very interesting
uh path that we were
we went through really
and maria maria whether it with uh
whether it's this maria or what we saw
you do in borat you don't seem the type
or you seem the type who is willing to
sort of go to extremes in order to tell
a story
yeah well yeah um you know i've always
been scared of
being in the middle part of the feelings
i always like to jump from one edge to
another edge and i think also that's
what art supposed to do to provoke
because either way we just can i don't
know lay on our sofa and
read something
but even if you're reading something
it's supposed to again make you feel
something provoke you to do an action
and to make this world a better place
which is the goal of every single movie
that we see um whether this is a comedy
or it's a drama i think in women to cry
we pretty much mixed
comedy and tragedy which is this perfect
example of british cinema for me that is
a very thin line between
something very committed and something
very
tragical
actress you didn't expect them
because you came from the academy and
you were more into these serious parts
right
yeah well by the way before borah i've
never done comedy in my life but now
when i see women to cry i see that it's
very funny
and i don't know maybe i'm just weird
and awkward in my life which the way
that i deliver things it might be
funny because i'm awkward because i'm
weird i don't know but definitely the
extremes are
attracting me um and i'm
more
i don't know
drown this direction to to go there
because i want to see what is happening
up there instead of just yeah well
it's fine
it's secure
there is a quote i'm not sure maybe kurt
cobain has said it uh your comfort zone
will kill you
and your inspiration and i pretty much
rely on that i believe that a lot
and uh mina and vezila um
when uh
when you do look at a when you do look
at a story like this and what those days
must have been like because watching it
at times it's difficult to watch
um what do you
what sort of mood do you set on set when
so many of the people were were family
and some of the subject matter was uh
was was heavy what kind of mood do you
guys make sure carries over onto the set
whether you're shooting or not
well the main driving force for us is
the satirical one so basically try and
tackle each situation with the utmost
humor and a little bit of sarcasm as
well so it was our driving force and one
of the main characters who came into
mind was this father who pays the women
still sorts out their lives and
basically the tragedy where you you're a
failure and that makes yours laugh
because each one of us has been in this
place and we can say that everybody has
his own failure
and it makes up so
funny uh situations oh yeah so the
country is very funny so it's not good
you know before it goes out east we
should explore our own place
and
actually it was like uh
because it was a big
mobilization
because we were ready to to show
ourselves
not only
naked physically but also naked
psychologically
within going to extremes and everybody
um was ready to go to beyond their even
imagination which was
it's a professional work they do really
such a great acting performance is
brilliant
i mean
blood out you know this is blood on the
laptop it's her own blood we didn't ask
her
so wild maria you have had just like an
incredible breakout breakthrough uh
since we all saw you in borah what has
that ride been like
exciting
honorable um flattering
it's been it's been amazing and
i've been happy to be busy
and to be talking with people like you
to be working with people like me and
vessela to be
searching for the new challenge that
i don't know
film industry will offer me to do um and
i don't know my
my forever inspiration will be to just
keep working because i believe that you
can always do better you can always go
higher you can always do something
bigger you can always
make people do something
more
influential um so it's been it's been
just inspiring and i just want to keep
working
because that's that's the industry that
i've chosen and if i can use that
platform to to shine light on some
problems and hopefully
help a little bit to show them that
that's the goal
when you start when you start dealing
with these hollywood movies you know you
always start thinking sequel everything
else borat is the type of movie and that
character you played in that movie it's
almost like you can never do that again
is there a world where you could hook up
with sasha again and do something
together or is it or is it burned
already well i will always want to work
with
here's the thing i'm pretty loyal as a
person and i do always want to work with
people that i work before again and
again and again even if it's the same
thing a sequel or something new
so
i would always want to work with sasha
and
today is my i don't know my child
something that
we've created together and i'm pretty
interested to see what is going to
happen with her future her destiny she's
a feminist as well at the end of the
movie she's like don't miss playing to
me and pretty much like sonia and women
do cry so we will see but maybe i don't
know these these things are pretty
unique and you're right sometimes it's
pretty challenging to go back there
especially
but but if he called you would do it
yeah yeah definitely
i think that distinguishes maria is that
she's very well read and for her young
age i mean she's uh this sort of uh
culture that she has is deeply kind of
soaked in her nature and her acting
abilities so i think she's gonna be a
good writer eventually i hope
yeah
before i let you go uh two quick things
uh maria what was it like working uh on
the bubble
oh
well the bubble came in a time when
we just started the promotion for borat
um in january last year and we were
pretty much
in a bubble shooting the bubble in
england because that catches the time
between january and april where it was
the biggest lockdown when you basically
weren't allowed to go for a walk with
more than one person uh but being on set
and being with
your peers and just
learning more and new things because in
the bubble i've i've been around people
that have been
incredible comedians
people that are very much familiar with
impro uh and it's been it's been
incredible and working with judd has
been a dream for real and uh and body's
body's bodies pete davidson is like the
most popular person in the world right
now
yeah um we shot a body's body's bodies
right after the bubble i literally came
to l.a for 10 days and then it's like
hey
we're we're ready we're going to new
york we're going to tear it down and we
started shooting body's body's bodies
which
was my dream to work with a24 because i
i love their craft a lot and everybody
in the team was pretty much incredible
from pete to amandla to mahala
to chasey wonders lee pace uh rachel
senor just a group of young people that
have been
dedicated to their craft and
with a leader in the face of helena
reign was incredible i think helena mina
and vesua
shared the same experience in lucano
pretty much because helena's first movie
instinct
have premiered there and i think they're
incredible back then and working with i
don't know just working with strong
women
yeah and one man as well like p davidson
and lee pace has been influential and
important and yeah i cannot wait to see
what his body's bodies because it's
going out two days after women to cry in
south by southwest
so yeah congratulations on women do cry
congratulations on can south by
southwest um i wish you guys nothing but
the absolute best and it was a joy
talking to all of you today thank you
thank you